[Música]
hola buenas noches mi nombre es 90 años
el periodista lidera una fundación en
chile que se llama cocina mar trabajamos
directamente con los pescadores para dar
a conocer sus productos también para que
los chilenos consuma más pescados pero
no cualquier pescado un pescado que
viene de la vez que responsable que
tengo nombre y apellido
y desde este año tenemos un rendimiento
como con todos socios que son cocineros
están aquí que visten la paula y es un
proyecto que tiene que ver con cómo
difundimos y cómo vamos a conocer los
más de 200 recursos pesqueros que están
disponibles en el agua que no se extraen
y que podrían mejorar las economías
locales de las caletas de pescadores el
proyecto se llama 3p y uno de pesca
responsable estará en valparaíso
para que funcione esto estamos
trabajando con caletas desde arica hasta
un lugar en la región de los lagos
trabajamos directamente con los
pescadores sin intermediarios
trabajamos con caletas que están en el
continente acá le requisó de urbanas y
también caleta está muy alejada como en
el caso del archipiélago juan fernández
con un pub hernández trabajado
directamente con daniel que está en las
fotos daniel gonzález es un pescador
pero también tuvo la oportunidad de en
el continente estudiar trabajaba en un
banco y cuando fue el tsunami en 2010 él
volvió volvió junto a toda una
generación a reconstruir su pueblo y
desde esa época ha liderado un proceso
que tiene que ver con conservación
marina contarle valor a sus productos
con mantener la pesquería ancestral de
la langosta y en este caso es la primera
vez quería en chile que cuenta con una
certificación de sustentabilidad
en el caso de la langosta también es la
primera que tiene como recurso pesquero
denominación de origen y ellos han
liderado también todo un proceso de no
depender solamente de la importación de
la langosta y por lo tanto varios de
suciedad generaciones cuentan ahora con
pymes oficiales que pueden comercializar
productos al continente en el caso de
nosotros con también somos muy amigos y
coordinamos estacó a través de whatsapp
desde desde el bote y nos avisa que es
lo que capturó puede ser bacalao puede
ser vidrio la pues en muchos de los
pescados que nosotros no conocemos nos
envía también muestras y ese pescado se
envía desde con fernández en el barco
cada 15 días y llega hasta acá a
valparaíso con toda la formalidad una
pyme con facturas con la habitación de
sernapesca y nos permite a nosotros
desde tres peces poder probar productos
y a nuestros clientes también la
oportunidad de probar el producto
increíble como el pulpo
el pulpo es un recurso endémico que es
alimento de langosta en nuestro caso soy
bastante humilde entonces no podemos
comprar la langosta pero si tenemos
disponible el pulpo para degustar está
impresionante es todo este proceso que
tiene que ver con cómo los pescadores
saltan desde la captura también a la
comercialización es un tremendo cambio
del modelo de negocio alguien
comercializa fruta o bebida y llega con
un furgón directo a un restaurant hay
todo un proceso también de entender cómo
funciona el mar y de entender lo que hay
a veces y ahí no a veces no sale nada o
sea que dependemos las mareas de las
temporadas y en eso hemos tenido una
oportunidad única desde tres peces de
poder trabajar con los productos de
temporada y con lo que la mar nos da
tenemos varios amigos pescadores amigas
que comercializan productos del mar a
quienes compramos directamente ella no
sé si necesita la presentación es la
reineta flaca tiene más de 10 mil
seguidores en facebook tiene un puesto
en la caleta portales está ahora pasando
un pequeño problema pero yo creo que lo
va a resolver bien y a todas las mañanas
cuando no llega el pescado fresco que
viene desde los botes de su hermano que
está el ego en la octava región a lo
anuncia por internet avisa no solamente
por facebook avisa también a través de
un grupo de whatsapp que tiene con sus
distintos los dueños del restaurante
chef con el equipo sus clientes y según
eso comercializa a pescado fresco cuando
no hay cuando su hermano no ha salido
bueno obviamente no estaba en el puesto
no es necesario no había mercado
con ella trabajamos directamente y no
solamente vende pescado ella está siendo
educación también en la foto ustedes
pueden ver cómo está con un grupo de
estudiantes mostrándole como una una
reineta cómo identificar un pescado
fresco como es el color de las agallas
es esto basando en la pesca artesanal y
en distintas localidades en este caso de
valparaíso
otro gran amigo es carlos castro él es
un pescador lleva más de 40 años en el
mar desde que aprende a escribir el papá
lo mandó al mar todas sus familias de
pescadores él no es dueño de una
embarcación es un tripulante lo que
significa que
el sueldo cierto depende de lo que se
capturó hay días que son buenos días son
malos y luego ese pescado que se captura
que llega hasta la caleta el membrillo
se vende al precio que se decida en a
pie de bote o sea puede ser un presión
muy muy bajo hay veces que se negocia a
200 pesos el kilo 3000 pesos la docena
de merluza y los vectores tienen poco
poder de negociar precio porque en
definitiva tampoco tienen la capacidad
de almacenar guardar o decidir bueno hoy
día está mal el precio mañana lo vendo
a los castros lo conocemos porque con él
hemos trabajado muchísimo más de tres
años haciendo talleres degustaciones él
nos provee de los productos del mar como
la jibia que tiene dirigido por teña y
cuál es el problema que efectivamente
cuando solo le compramos productos a
veces menos donaba no teníamos la
formalidad para poder respaldar esta
compra
desde enero de este año él tiene una
empresa formal con su mujer con roxana
que se llama san pedro por lo tanto
ahora puede comercializar directamente
ya no solo nosotros como tres peces sino
distintos restoranes en a domicilio y de
nuevo todo está ocupando tecnología tan
simple como un teléfono whatsapp
facebook por lo tanto nosotros le
preguntamos tiene disponible la merluza
nos avisa que sí o no y nos trae
directamente al restaurante a un precio
mucho mejor de lo que él podía negociar
desde el bote y un precio que está
nosotros también es súper atractivo
porque porque en la cadena de
comercialización de estilo al menos hay
seis intermediarios lo que significa que
el pescado al final del día en cuestión
qué es lo que quiero contar con todo
esto que en el mundo de la pesca
artesanal se están generando distintas
espacios de comercialización y en eso a
través de la fundación cocina mar y
ahora más actualmente a través de tres
pesos de este restaurant de pesca
responsable estamos liderando un proceso
para que para poder acceder a pescados
mariscos crustáceos algas en un mar que
somos privilegiados donde consumimos muy
poca cantidad pues subimos cinco o seis
recursos quizás diez y tenemos más de
210 especies en el agua que se pueden
extraer tenemos más de 120 pescados
distintos que podríamos darle valor y no
los conocemos o no están disponibles
porque pensábamos que no había interés
resulta que desde este piloto que
estamos implementando podemos ahora
decir que sí que hay fanáticos de los
pescados que hay gente incluso siendo
vegetariana quiere probar los pescados
porque saben de dónde viene saber el
origen saben el arte de pesca
y también hay todo un camino que hay que
avanzar que tiene que ver con la
educación con respetar las vedas las
temporadas las tallas mínimas con
entender que no es posible que teniendo
más de 99 pescadores en un largo todos
chile más de 450 caleta de pescadores
estemos importando tanto pescado y estén
los pescados cortados como la tilapia el
pan nació en las cartas como si éstos
fueran los animales siendo que tenemos
nosotros proteína marina yo lo puedo
entender en ciudades que son cordilleras
de difícil acceso pero aquí es donde
tenemos dos caletas urbanas que podemos
llegar en transporte público me parece
ilógico y eso son las cosas nos estamos
tratando a mejorar porque es sube
importante también y tiene que ver con
la economía local y como nosotros
también queremos la ciudad el futuro se
acto para que esto funcione desde cocina
mar llevamos varios años recorriendo las
caletas trabajando con proyectos y
armamos una red de emprendedores o sea
estos mismos datos que teníamos que
tenemos los teléfonos nos contestan los
facebook
decimos bueno esto tiene que ser público
y tenemos una plataforma que se llama
cocina mar punto cl hay un botón que
dice red donde donde tenemos
identificado a 28 organizaciones de
pescadores hombres mujeres recolectores
de orilla dueños de plantas de proceso
productores de conservas de ahumados
dónde están sus productos disponibles y
nosotros no somos el comerciante somos
una ventana para que esto pueda ser
visible y para que ellos puedan hacer su
comercialización en forma directa eso es
cocina mar pero resulta que ahora con
tres peces también somos clientes
también hacemos el ejercicio de cómputo
y resulta que llegan los productos
no sé si bien al señor rojo al león el
lucero él tiene una empresa desde el ego
hace una dos increíbles y las hacen
llegar a valparaíso sin ningún problema
nos ha acompañado a ferias gastronómicas
hemos estado aquí en la expo vino y cada
vez que la abre un frasco que da a
probar la gente vuelve a recordar sus
sabores del iesa es ese ahumado
artesanal con también al menos 15
pescados distintos que no siempre están
en las cartas el trabajo confesor con
sierra con lo que es la mar la edad que
tiene una embarcación
y pasa lo mismo con las algas con muchos
productos entonces cuando nosotros
hablamos de qué es lo que queremos que
pase en esta ciudad el futuro qué es lo
que queremos que valparaíso gustaría no
sólo que haya tanta tecnología o
innovación también volver al pasado
volver al origen o sea tener la
capacidad de tener estos peces está el
vaquero increíble capturada en quintero
y que quiera que ganas de tener algo así
de nuevo disponible para nosotros
frescos
para eso llevamos varios años armando un
modelo de negocio que tiene que ver con
una venta por suscripción de pescado
fresco congelado a domicilio hace ya dos
o tres años atrás participamos de un
proyecto de innovación social del live
the social lab que se llamaba buen
puerto a camps el paraíso ganáramos como
una iniciativa que tenía que ver con
como empoderamos a las organizaciones de
pescadores
desde ese momento hice un piloto y que
funcionaba o sea alguien podría pagar
unos 10 mil pesos por ejemplo por equis
kilos de pescado o proteína marina y te
podría llegar a tu casa pero pagada por
adelantado los pescadores cosa que ellos
puedan extraer productos que no
necesariamente son los que ahora extraen
y que están sobreexplotados
ese modelo que para nosotros tiene mucho
sentido ahora también tiene más sentido
considerando que tenemos un restaurant
que sirve también de baraguá para todo
este trabajo
seguimos facturando no no hemos ganado
ningún fondo para poder implementarlo
pero si desde los últimos 3 años a la
fecha tenemos formación sabemos que los
chilenos no son tan ajenos a los
productos del mar
o sea que si les gusta que si hay una
generación nueva que quiere probar que
quiere alimentarse bien que si tenemos
muchas organizaciones de pescadores que
están dispuestos a hacer este mega salto
que es la comercialización y además que
hay recursos pesqueros que no son los
tradicionales que todavía están
disponibles como les decía al principio
tenemos 210 recursos pesqueros que se
podrían extraer pero no se sacan del
agua principalmente porque creemos que
en el mercado pero tenemos en la costa
más de 1.200 especies pesqueras
identificadas que no en este momento no
tienen valor comercial
aquí el pescado es el modelo ojalá
suceda de esto pronto y cuando decía que
estamos hablando de la ciudad de futuro
pero también hay que ser respetuosos con
lo que ha pasado para el mar este está
esta conversación cierto estuvimos
revisando noticias
valparaíso como en el tema de
comercialización ante nosotros
encontramos con una campaña del año 72
que el implemento corfo acá en la caleta
en un brillo y hay un titular de un
diario y eso no se ve bien pero dice
aquí se regala la merluza en el año 72
en la caleta el membrillo había una
planta de proceso asociado a una escuela
de ciencias del mar había camiones
refrigerados que llevaban estas filetes
de merluza a las carnicerías de los
cerros y bajo en qué momento nos
perdimos corzo contrató tres barcos
pesqueros de la unión soviética para
poder capturar los pescados
porque hay interés en el producto del
mar tiene características de sobra para
ser positivas
en nuestro caso hace dos años estamos
realizando una actividad que se mal día
la merluza junto a obra ong que se llama
wwf el año pasado hicimos un evento en
portales este año fue en el membrillo
donde estamos justamente 600 pescados o
merluza a la comunidad preparadas la
lata entonces y luego esto que estamos
volviendo a repetir sea esta instancia
pero tenemos que darle más forma y ahora
sí sabemos que tenemos pescadores no
digan ni solamente las instituciones de
afuera armar algo ahora ya sabemos que
los pescadores están absolutamente
empoderados para hacerse cargo de estos
procesos de comercialización y por otro
lado si tenemos que tener consumidores
responsables que conozcan el origen de
los productos y que les interesa también
respetar las temporadas
en nuestro caso estamos con esta
propuesta que nos tiene de verdad muy
contento nos permite jugar nos permite
aceptó una creación de preparaciones
gastronómicas hay un tremendo equipo
detrás para cocinar lo que llega del día
no tenemos la carta hecha hay una carta
flexible de productos del mar
sólo tenemos pescados mariscos y
crustáceos algas no tenemos menú de
niños no tenemos otras carnes y no
porque estemos en contra la gente
divide las familias entendemos que los
productos del mar son increíbles a todo
nivel y por lo tanto algo que debería
empezar a gustar y queremos también que
la gente deje de tener ese susto pánico
de ciertos productos porque tuvieron una
mala de prueba o porque no tuviera una
buena experiencia con algún producto o
en alguna otra ocasión entonces quiero
que están tratando de hacer barrio
comunidad que se entienda la importancia
que tienen las caletas de pescadores en
este caso cuando inauguramos el restorán
en el cerro concepción tres peces
hicimos un almuerzo comunitario para más
de 300 vecinos donde ocupamos 200
recursos pesqueros de 13 caletas de
todos chile es una herramienta logística
y eso pasará
y si ven las fotos están acá van a ver
que en primera fila hay unos señores
mayores y estos son unos máster de
ciencias del mar o sea esos hombres
tienen la sabiduría en torno lo que está
pasando en el mar sentados con
pescadores con vecinos con la familia
poniendo también lo que queremos que
suceda aquella conversación una
educación y volver a mirar lo que
tenemos aquí que es increíble
y esto no lo podemos hacer solos o sea
que hay muchas organizaciones que están
detrás de este trabajo trabajamos muy
ligados con ong trabajamos muy ligados
con más de 40 organizaciones con las
confederaciones de pescadores
y me gusta mucho este titular que habla
de la cofradía gastronómica porque
justamente eso es lo que queremos que
pase que se vuelva a este pueblo
gastronómico que va al paraíso vuelva a
despertar de productos que estaban antes
que estaban que están en el agua todavía
y que la gente vuelva a disfrutar del
mar como en la época de las abuelas con
la cocina de las abuelas también entre
especias tenemos un plato
clásico siendo que llevamos poquito
tiempo que es el pescado el ata que es
cómo se comía antes en casa entonces es
lo que queremos que se renueve y esa
foto habla también como estamos tratando
de trabajar en comunidad en la foto
están mis dos socios cristian y paula de
tres peces y también están dos amigos
cocineros de restoranes de acá
valparaíso y es el puerto claro y el
verso porque en definitiva así tiene que
ser los compartimos datos no compartimos
historias compartimos eventos fuimos
todos juntos a santiago a un evento
gastronómico que se nos puedan servir
fuimos en adelante fuimos presentando a
valparaíso
porque tenemos que unidos vamos a
avanzar mucho más rápido y es la
invitación eso tiene que ver con lo que
estamos trabajando hace bastante tiempo
es que tiene que ver con disfrutar estos
sabores que hay en el mar que son
increíbles y por lo tanto la invitación
es a subirse al bote muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah